well as you know the left has tried its
best to ignore my film what is a woman
even as it has dominated the
conversation become the most popular
streaming movie in the country this
month according to rotten tomatoes um
that's not to say they haven't
criticized the documentary they have
it's just that they they've criticized
it from a safe distance and without
actually watching it first but it's come
to my attention that one person on the
left
or one left and and one left-wing
publication um
did actually watch the movie and just
this one as far as i know or they claim
to have watched it anyway and i would be
remiss if i did not acknowledge this
brave soul and honor her for her efforts
but i can only give full credit if she
watches the film and then engages with
it and criticizes it honestly and it's
on this last step that the writer aaron
rook of the publication lgbtq nation
kind of uh tends to falter still i think
it could be worthwhile to
go through this critique because it
shows once again i think just how
totally flimsy and bereft of logic the
other side of this discussion truly is
while trying to debunk the film she only
manages to prove most of the major
points in the film as we'll see
so rook delivers her commentary in a
review titled
quote the dangerous deception of matt
walsh's documentary what is a woman we
watched matt walsh's anti-trans
propaganda so you don't have to spoiler
alert it's full of transphobic lies
that sounds pretty bad full of
transphobic lies now before delving into
what she claims are the myths propagated
by the film rook writes quote the film
is slickly produced
thank you and includes interviews with
some reputable sources but walsh seems
more interested in exposing these
efforts that these experts than actually
learning from them he also allows his
anti-transgender sources to spout off
dangerous disinformation
unchecked now that's incorrect i was not
interested in exposing them and i did
not expose them they exposed themselves
figuratively anyway i mean one guy in
san francisco literally exposed himself
but as for the so-called experts they
exposed the vacuousness of their own
world view i didn't do anything except
provide them a forum for this
self-destruction uh and that's all we
did that that was the whole point we
just asked questions she then proceeds
to list the film's most malignant myths
now let's go through these
these are the myths propagated
in uh my film it says myth
trans people who medically transition
are at increased risk of suicide
and she could she explains in an effort
to portray gender transition as
dangerous the film includes the
assertion that trans the transition
makes people suicidal this claim is
likely rooted in a misinterpretation of
the research promoted by
anti-transgender psychiatrist dr paul
mchugh in a 2014 wall street journal
op-ed but the 2011 swedish study he
references was not designed to evaluate
the efficacy of gender affirmation
surgeries and its authors caution
against such an interpretation trans
journalist kristen williams
interviewed lead author dr cecilia de
jing who expressed her frustration at
the ways in which her research had been
misrepresented quote i've even seen
professors use my work to support
ridiculous claims i've often had to
respond myself by commenting on articles
speaking with journalism talking about
this problem at conferences people who
misuse the study always omit the fact
that the study clearly states that it's
not an evaluation of gender dysphoria
treatment if we look at the literature
we find that several recent studies
include a conclude that wpath standards
of care compliant treatment decrease
gender dysphoria and improve mental
health
okay now
um the fact that the authors of the
study the swedish study
were not trying to prove that gender
affirmation surgery quote unquote big
scare quotes around that increases
suicidality
and yet they proved it anyway
only makes the results more compelling
not less that study no matter what the
authors of the study would prefer or how
they'd like us to read the data
clearly shows that trans people are the
most suicidal a decade after the surgery
again
according to the author of the study as
this article points out this one author
that's not what she was trying to prove
that's not what she set out to do and
yet she proved it
so this is these are results that cut
against
the biases apparently of the people who
conducted the study which just makes the
results all the more convincing
this is what the data shows planet plain
as day
and that's why in this attempt to debunk
the quote myth the writer never actually
says outright that the claim about
suicide ali is wrong she she cautions
against misinterpretation but does not
attempt to refute it because she can't
and that's because the data is clear
in fact every study that's ever been
done by anyone anywhere shows that trans
people pre-op post-op no op affirmed
unaffirmed no matter what
have suicide rates significantly higher
than the general population
this clearly indicates that there is
something deeper going on inside the
mind that it's a problem in the mind
which is why surgeries can't fix it and
as this study shows
don't fix it
you know what you know notice what else
our friend aaron doesn't do
she doesn't provide any contrary
evidence at all this is a theme that
will continue throughout the article and
it continues with with any attempt to
debunk my movie or to debunk any of the
the arguments that we make on the um
anti-gender ideology side
they never prevent they never present
any evidence to prove their assertions
she debunks the claims in my film
without really refuting them
and without providing any evidence to
support her
position so kind of a rough start start
but let's see if things maybe get a
little bit better continuing um
it says quote myth gender affirming
surgeries are experimental and dangerous
she explains some of the worst
fear-mongering comes from transgender
man scott nugent who is on a crusade
against medical transition for youth in
the film nugent says that gender
affirming surgery comes with a 67
complication risk and shows the scar
from his phalloplasty related skin graft
for dramatic effect phalloplasty a
complex procedure is not without risk of
complications however rates are much
lower than the 67
nugent claims and vary depending on the
approach taken by the surgeon a 2017
study found that rates of urethral
complications were between 31.5 and 32.8
percent depending on the approach it's
also not the most commonly sought
transition related surgery
transmasculine individuals are much more
likely to seek a double mastectomy aka
top surgery which has a complication
rate of about 12 and many trans people
don't seek any surgical interventions
which casts doubt on his claim that for
every child convinced to transition big
pharma rakes in 1.3 million
okay
now
actually
the 67 figure uh may be vastly
understating it depending on what study
you look at also depending on how you
define complication
but let's just go with her figure for
the sake of argument
she's trying to debunk the myth
quote unquote that gender affirming
surgeries are experimental and dangerous
and she does so by favorably citing a
study that says rates of complication
are over 30 percent
that's extraordinarily high 30 percent
complication right
she's taking the very low end of the
complication rate okay the most generous
study she could find
and she still must admit it's a rate at
a minimum at best of over 30 percent
and this proves that it's
not dangerous
how so
and how in the world could this prove
that it's not experimental
she takes refuge in the fact that double
mastectomies have only only a 12
complication rate still very high but
she ignores the fact that the primary
complication with cutting off a woman's
healthy breasts is that you've cut off a
woman's healthy breasts
the complication is that you've removed
a piece of her body a piece of her and
you've done it on the theory that it
will help her to be a man even though
she could never be a man and chopping
off her breasts will bring her no closer
to manhood than she was when she still
had them
the fact that there are allegedly only
quote unquote additional complications
and 12 percent of cases does not rescue
you from this fact it's the surgery
itself that's the
problem even if everything goes
perfectly well when you're cutting the
breasts off of a off of a woman
you're still cutting her breasts off
and that's the issue
you are removing healthy body parts and
often you're doing this to young girls
who would not even be allowed to legally
get tattoos because they've been judged
too young for it
finally it's insisted that many trans
people don't get surgeries which she
says cast doubt on the claim that every
child who transitions rakes in 1.3
million for big pharma now with this
rebuttal the writer is simply pretending
i guess that hormone pills and puberty
blockers don't exist
because obviously when we're talking
about the money that big pharma makes
off of all of this we're primarily
talking about the pills and the
injections
but okay
that none of that exists apparently okay
incredible
now that concludes basically the the
closest thing to an attempt at a real
rebuttal that you'll find in the article
though she does continue listing myths
while the debunking efforts get lazier
and lazier as she goes along she
addresses the myth in the film that
quote real transgender people are rare
and she does this by pointing to a ucla
study that claims point six percent of
the population is trans now
that would still qualify as rare by any
definition of the word rare that i've
ever heard point six percent but she
then she then notes that a recent pew
study found that five percent of young
people identify as trans
but that doesn't refute anything we say
in the film in fact
we claim in the film that trans
identification is skyrocketing among
young people she's agreeing with us not
refuting us that's our point
okay so again using using the numbers
presented point six percent general
population
fine that's still
insanely high but fine what point six
percent
five percent for people under 30.
how in the world do you explain that
well our point is that this astronomical
rise is due to social contagions and
indoctrination
she makes no attempt to address that
next she tries to debunk my claim that
children can't choose their own gender
and she does that by assuring us that in
fact
it's quote widely accepted by pediatric
professionals that children can choose
their genders
that's it it's widely accepted so move
on
now it's true it is widely accepted and
one of the main points of our film is to
reveal that this wide acceptance is not
rooted in any coherent underlying logic
like i totally agree that it's widely
accepted that's one of the reasons we
made the movie
but we're trying to discover is why is
it so widely accepted
and what we discovered is that it's not
widely accepted based on any kind of
rational
logical basis unless you want to talk
about profit motive as a rational
logical basis basis
finally she seeks to debunk the myth
quote unquote
that transgender identities are a modern
western invention
um and and she claims that on this topic
quote
walsh hasn't done his homework
well i literally went to africa
i mean it's harder to do more homework
than that on something like this the
writer on the other hand did much more
extensive research by googling it for
five seconds
and from her googling she learned about
native american two-spirit identities
and the hedra in india and she says that
these are examples of non-western trans
identities
the problem is that the two-spirit
designation was invented by lgbt
activists in america in the 90s so it is
itself a modern western invention okay
the comanche on the great plains weren't
going around calling themselves
two-spirit and transgender didn't exist
um as for the
alleged variation in india the groups
you refers to are not traditionally seen
as trans in the way that we use the term
this is a spiritual concept often
referring to eunuchs who undergo
castration rituals
this is not the same as the belief that
men can actually be women
okay so this is a really important point
to prove
that transgenderism is not uniquely
modern in western you would have to find
non-western cultures where they believe
men can actually literally be women and
women can literally be men not
spiritually or figuratively or
performatively but literally
you'd have to find somewhere that
believes a pregnant person can be a man
an actual man
and you'd have to prove that this
culture had this idea came up with it on
its own and that it wasn't introduced to
them by westerners
now um you won't find that because it
doesn't exist i'll just make it easy for
you not going to find it doesn't exist
just as you won't find any actual
rebuttals in this rebuttal or in any
other rebuttal of what is a woman
but she did watch the movie at least
next time she should probably watch it
with her eyes open and the ear plugs out
you might actually learn something
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated
you